what we have now among the contemporary
left is simply relativism so they
tolerate things because they think they
are equally valid hey I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Reuben report real quick
everyone don't forget to click that
subscribe button and make sure
notifications are turned on so that you
actually get our videos
okay then joining me today is a British
columnist and the editor of spiked
online and a former Reuben report guest
who we decided to welcome back
Brendan O'Neill welcome back to the
Reuben hey Dave how's again it is going
well I'm glad to have you back it was
about two years ago that we sat down for
the first time and I kind of think that
your political philosophy is pretty much
in line with mine but yeah over the pond
so we're dealing with different
different issues but before we get into
any of that this shirt no one has wore
flowers show believe it's so hot in LA I
get as a as a as a Britain of Irish
descent yes he is just unmanageable so I
had to put on the lightest flower yes
thing that I could find
all right well hence the shirt let's get
into some flowery pollen and so just
quickly for those that don't know who
you are at all we did about an hour and
a half talk already so they can check
out that video will link to it below but
let's just do like a little 4 or 5
minute kind of recap of who you are who
spiked is and and sort of just your
general political philosophy yes so I am
I call myself a left-wing libertarian I
mean it's not the most accurate term it
has very various failings but I think
it's probably the best fit for me
watching we're really probably antennas
going up what are you left-wing yeah
exactly so a lot of people think it's a
contradiction in terms right because the
left has become so incredibly
authoritarian so since Laureus so
divisive so difficult to deal with you
know there are so many problems with a
contemporary left that if you compare if
you have the word left in the same
sentence as the word liberal or
libertarian or freedom people think
that's a contradiction in terms so I
completely understand that but I see
myself as coming from a tradition where
leftist people were in favor of freedom
they were in favor of freedom of speech
they're in favor of counter cultural
experimentation they were in favor of
allowing people to make jokes to write
books to create art however offensive it
may have been so there is a left
tradition which is which does value
freedom which does value Liberty which
does value choice and I see myself as
coming from that tradition unfortunately
that tradition is fading away so people
like me seem quite eccentric but I still
think it's worth holding on to
yeah so I hear your brother in that that
pool myself do you find that sort of
staying in that position and saying a
left libertarian to try to say fix it
from the inside as opposed to maybe
working with people that you might not
have worked with before and I think this
will be particularly apropos when we
talk about brexit I found that working
with people on the right is much more
fruitful leas yes but I respect the
people that are still trying to fix it
from the inside I don't see it happening
especially in the context of American
politics it seems to be getting worse
and worse but when you say Leffler
retired is that because you're still
trying to kind of fix sort of what's
going on with leftism from from inside
the machine no I don't think leftism is
fixable I mean I I spend my whole life
in a state of kind of just
apoplectic fury with the left I'm so
disappointed with what has become of the
left I cannot believe that a movement
that started out with the values of
universalism
has become this identitarian divisive a
hyper racialist outfit which is
constantly obsessing over whether you're
white or black or and defining everyone
by the biological boxes that they spend
so long trying to escape from I can't
believe that a left which was
traditionally Pro economic growth Pro
Progress wanted to industrialize the
entire third world has become this kind
of environmentalist
save the planet recycle your rubbish
kind of middle class environmentalist
movement so I I spend all my time it's
just feeling so disappointed with what
the left has become and I've reached the
conclusion that I don't think it can be
saved
but I but having said that I do think
and I do work with people on the right
I think alliances across left-right you
know from conservative to radical
whatever it might be I think alliances
are the key feature of contemporary
politics and I think the great dividing
line now is no longer left versus right
no longer a capitalist versus communist
the really important dividing line is
now between do you believe in freedom do
you trust ordinary people to decide for
themselves how they should live or do
you not believe in freedom are you an
authoritarian do you think people need
to be controlled and cajoled and told
what to think I think that's the key
dividing line and I'm willing to work
with and align with anyone who is on the
side of saying we trust people to make
up their own minds and to decide for
themselves how they should live their
lives so by the time we post this video
because everyone knows I'm going off the
grid I will have just handed in my
manuscript for my book and one of the
things that I'm talking about in there
is that perhaps there is a flaw within
that tradition that you're talking about
that I love so much that perhaps within
liberalism itself and the nature of
Tolerance itself and and a removal of
some of the sort of religious
underpinnings that came before the
Enlightenment that there is a something
broken within liberalism it is something
that I don't want to really think about
or even to have to analyze because
that's a scary thought for you know
senator people to have to think about
that this is of course what Sam Harris
and Jordan Peterson had been debating a
lot for the last year and a half and
many others a Ben Shapiro wrote a book
about it do you think there is something
to that I do think there's something to
that I do think there's a god-shaped
hole in contemporary society lots of
people have written about the god-shaped
hole and how you fill it and it's very
difficult to fill it and and nothing
particularly convincing has filled it
thus far but I'm an atheist I don't
believe in God I it's a very tough one
but I know I was brought up a Catholic
so I was brought up very religious I was
an altar boy until I was 16 years old
and I know I've never been anti
religious in the way that some of the
new atheists are I
always understood religion can play an
incredibly important role in people's
lives in terms of providing a framework
providing a moral framework providing
community connections I think it plays
an incredibly important role so I've
never had this kind of anti religious
sometimes quite snobby paternalistic
approach to people who believe in God
but at the same time I think where the
Enlightenment has gone wrong where
Enlightenment values have gone wrong is
not necessarily because the
Enlightenment kind of pushed God aside
and said you know Humanity is the center
and we should we should organize elves
or organize ourselves around the hue
humanist ideal I don't think that's the
problem with Enlightenment ideals I
think the the key problem is that the
the Enlightenment ideal of tolerance
which is so important that you tolerate
people even if you disagree with them
you tolerate people even if you think
their values are backward you you value
freedom so much that you're willing to
tolerate people who wear the burqa or
who say outrageous things or who say
racist things because you think freedom
is the core overarching value of coffe
Society I think the problem is that
tolerance has transmogrified into
relativism and so if you look back at
the Enlightenment value of tolerance it
wasn't only saying you have to tolerate
everything and put up with it it was
saying you should tolerate everything in
the name of freedom but at the same time
you are allowed to criticize these
things right so it was I was born as a
two-way street yeah in a weird way now
it's become a one-way absolutely right
so it was a two-way street in the sense
that you would tolerate even backward
beliefs and stupid beliefs and wrong
beliefs you would tolerate them but you
would push back against them you would
say that's wrong that's inferior right
no one uses the word inferior anymore
that that's a bad way to live what we
have now
among the contemporary left is simply
relativism so they tolerate things
because they think they are equally
valid so so is that though because of
the guard shaped all do you do you make
that direct connection because this is
again I come from a secular place on it
yeah yet I find there's almost no way
I know many atheists that are the most
moral good yes generous people at that
micro level at the individual level or
small group level let's say but I'm
finding especially at a time going
against this radical leftist
authoritarian monster that that's why
liberalism is sputtering right now
because it has that that tolerance peace
that's now being used against it yes III
think that's a key problem of our times
I would argue and I say this as a
secularist and an atheist I would argue
that you don't need God in order to be
moral absolutely that you need something
and that's the key issue and what I
think has happened in in recent decades
is that the shift from a God arranged
society to something else has given rise
to this sense of relativism this sense
that everything is equally valid so in
the UK for example Boris Johnson who's
currently running to be leader of the
Tory Party and the next prime minister
he got into a huge amount of trouble for
criticizing the burka he said that women
who wear the burka look like bank
robbers they look like letterboxes they
look crazy I wish they wouldn't wear
this garment and and it causes huge
enormous fuss and people said he should
apologize and retract and these kind of
this furious woke Lobby were saying he
was Islamophobic and all these other
things accusations that they throw at
you what they overlooked is that in the
same article where he made these
ridiculing points he also said we have
to defend the right of women to wear
whatever they want to wear so I actually
thought that he actually summed up the
traditional view of Tolerance which is
that we tolerate people who wear the
burka even if we think it's a stupid
thing to wear and I actually share his
view on that but we also push back
against it we criticize it we say that
it's not a nice way for women to live
and so I think that's what's being lost
the the critical aspect of Tolerance
where you don't only tolerate people's
views and lifestyles but you also
criticize them that aspect is being lost
and I think that explains a lot of why
we're heading into this politically
correct woke culture in which are not
allowed to criticize anything how much
of that do you think then is directly
related to the media because the way you
just described
comments and he says you know I don't
want women to have to wear the burka but
they should be able to choose that's a
big butt right yeah absolutely this is
the type of thing we see with Trump or
almost anyone on the right all the time
these days there's a headline that
sounds awful and racist and whatever and
then you have to dig into you know page
a chapter you know paragraph 39 where
then you see the qualifying statement
and it's like oh well actually what they
said wasn't that bad I think that's
absolutely right I think the media has
an awful lot to answer for and so does
social media because what you have is a
situation today where anyone who makes a
statement even if it's a reasonable
statement social media and the media
will latch onto it and say you're racist
you're Islamophobic you're a misogynist
even if you are not criticizing
womankind not criticizing all Muslims
not criticizing all black people but
slightly a Muslim woman right exactly
you could be a Muslim woman who thinks
that it's wrong to ask Muslim women to
wear the hijab and you will be branded
Islamophobic for raising those points
this happened in the UK very recently
the Muslim Council of Britain issued a
report on suppose it is llama phobia in
the media and one of his examples was an
Iranian woman who refused to wear the
hijab which is required in Iran by the
way she refused to wear the hijab and
she went on to the BBC and gave an
interview on why she refused to ever hit
up she said it's an oppressive garment
she doesn't like wearing it the Muslim
Council of Britain in the UK held this
interview up as an example of
Islamophobia because they said it wasn't
given the other side and you think
yourself what is the other side the
other side is presumably the theocratic
Iranian Revolutionary Guard a point of
view which is that all women must wear
this garment or else they'll be punished
so you're absolutely right even Muslim
women who raise questions about the way
Muslim women live can be denounced as
Islamophobic can be denounced as
misogynistic and what we're entering
into is a society in which anyone who
raises any questions about cultural
values or social tensions or religious
tensions or anything else can be so
swiftly demonized as racist and phobic
and evil and beyond the pale and even as
a fascist and what that does it
contributes to a sense where you you you
just think there are certain things you
cannot say certain criticisms you cannot
raise and it's very cynically designed I
think to stifle debate about the
problems in society and then it
fascinatingly creates the sort of widest
tent in politics which is worldwide
right now which is the deplorable is
which you're talking a lot about I mean
the example I would give is is from
London I was there about six months ago
and I was on tour with Jordan Peterson
and I went to Harrods which is the
famous department store and something
like seventy percent of the women were
wearing burkas no I'm not look they can
wear whatever they want yeah I take the
liberal position on this of course I
would want them all to live as freely as
they possibly can and all that but what
I would say is I it struck me as odd
yeah I wasn't in Saudi Arabia I wasn't
in Iran but not only that and we having
nothing to do with racism or biggie or
any of those things which is so stupid
that I even have to elucidate that point
to you if there had if I had walked into
Harrods and there had been 70% Amish
women yeah Orthodox Jewish women or
something else that would be alternative
struck me as a little odd yeah this
doesn't feel like whatever London felt
like at one time and if you don't let
people just think about that or talk
about it then you're gonna lead to all
sorts of other crazy things absolutely
right I think Harrods and Selfridges
which is another famous posh shop in
London well the reason let me just want
to think the reason it struck me so hard
is because I am aware that we live in a
weird time related to terror and
everything else and that when you're in
a place that has I mean Harrods is just
packed you're just sort of yeah being
with the mob from room to room yes it's
so packed well if there were groups of
men that you could only see their eyes
yeah you would think it's alarming I
mean that just is it's it sounds
whatever but yeah just is but you know I
think I completely agree I think the
burka is a ridiculous offensive horrible
item of clothing I think the idea that a
woman needs to cover herself from head
to toe so that all you can see is her
eyes is ridiculous it's offensive to
women because
covers them in this black cloth and it's
offensive to men because the whole idea
of it is that these women are so
sexually attractive that men cannot
control their impulses
it's it's in a deeply offensive garment
I also happen to defend women's right to
wear it even though I know that's very
complicated because I know that lots of
women don't exercise free choice right
when they wear this garment but my great
concern is that if you were to say in in
the UK or France or Belgium if you were
to say you are banned from wearing this
garment in public my great concern is
that most of those women would not go
out in public so I think it would
actually limit their freedom in a way
that would be incredibly destructive but
this is the problem we face in
contemporary society where it's it's
become unacceptable to say I'd
absolutely defend your freedom to wear
this ridiculous item of clothing this
backward archaic medieval item of
clothing I defend your freedom to wear
that but I think you're wrong I think
it's it's antisocial I think it is it
makes life more difficult because I
cannot see your face I cannot engage
with you that's where I think political
correctness is really causing problems
where it's no longer acceptable to say
fine
do what you want to do but everyone else
must have the right to criticize what
you do instead we're all supposed to nod
along obediently at all these various
different ways of life even if we know
inside our hearts and minds that it's a
wrong way to live so the expectation of
political correctness that you must
simply obediently accept all lifestyles
I think is a serious problem yeah and
you sort of hit this when you said
anti-social but it also creates this odd
situation where you need to see
someone's yes to read cues you can't
restaurant you can read a lot in the
eyes but there's things about someone's
face and the way they lift their brow
and their moves and all of those things
that allow us to actually connect a
little bit more so then it creates a
secondary level of disconnect that's
right just what someone's where well you
know there was a case in the UK recently
where a woman who wears the niqab wanted
to be able to wear it in a court of law
where she was giving evidence and the
judge said no absolutely unacceptable
because we
to be able to see the movements on your
face we need we need to see what you're
thinking and in a court of law that
becomes a very pronounced issue right
because you need to know is this person
telling the truth and you judge people
by how they look how their eyes look how
their face looks the facial expressions
they make so I think I would be in favor
of restricting the right of women to
wear the Knik up in a court of law
because you need to be able to see the
face I also would be in favor of
restricting the right of women to wear
the niqab in a school because I think
young children need to be able to see
their teachers face and there's there's
currently big discussion about whether
women should be able to wear the Knik up
in schools in the UK and also in France
I think they shouldn't be allowed to
wear it so there are some areas where I
think the the anti-social element of
that clothing becomes so problematic
that it's acceptable to say you can't
wear it but in the public sphere in
every day walking down the street going
into a shop I would defend freedom the
freedom of women to wear this religious
garment and additional to that I would
defend the right of everyone else to
criticise the fact that these women wear
this garment without being branded
Islamophobic because that phobic
accusation is used so often these days
to brand anyone who simply raises
questions about Islam or transgenderism
or any aspect of contemporary woek
politics anyone who raises any any
criticism of that consent swiftly and
easily be denounced as phobic that it
just becomes incredibly difficult to
have an honest discussion about the
society we live in ok so I think that's
a perfect segue then when it comes to
having an honest discussion about what's
happening in contemporary society you've
been one of the most outspoken brexit
supporters and yet one of the people
that I think is kind of giving it its
intellectual backing so we touch on this
a little bit two years ago roughly so
it's hard to believe this is still being
discussed but for the layman who knows
nothing about brags in what was Bragg's
it about let's just do that in 2 or 3
minutes and then we'll get caught up to
where we're at now yes so in my view
brexit is the most important political
issue in the Western world what happened
is in June 2016 which is so long ago now
17 another world it's it's crazy
seventeen point four million British
people voted to leave the European Union
that's the largest bloc of voters in the
history of the United Kingdom that many
people have never voted for anything so
they voted to we includes me seventeen
point four million people voted to leave
the European Union because the European
Union is an anti-democratic technocratic
bureaucratic a liberal PC institution
which just drains the life out of
democracy and freedom of speech and all
these other key issues so we were right
I believe to oppose the European Union
so we voted against it the the idea was
that we would have this referendum and
whatever we decided would be acted upon
we were told that again and again and
again by David Cameron who was then the
Prime Minister three plus years later
we're still in the European Union we
haven't left and it looks increasingly
like we won't leave so there is now talk
of having a second referendum there is
now talk of simply overriding the vote
there is now talk of Parliament using
its power to deprive the public of the
thing that they voted for and simply
preventing it from happening I think if
that happens it will be it will be an it
will be a really key event in the
history of Britain because what it will
say is that we are no longer really a
democratic nation we are no longer
really a democracy we're no longer a
nation that takes seriously what
ordinary people think so I think a lot
of people across the Western world
really should be keeping a close eye on
breaks it because if breaks it doesn't
happen then the whole nature of
democracy the whole democratic era which
has only existed for a few hundred years
will be called into question because
basically at that point plenty of other
Western leaders who might have some
authoritarian tendencies might go well
yes it doesn't really matter if I win or
lose in election because look what
happened over there
we have delay and delay and delay long
enough until the people either start
flipping or we can make up enough lies
or demonize enough people and then
that's right Congrats to me
I'm still in power that's right and I
you know a lot of people used to look to
the United Kingdom for a democratic
example and I was thinking about this
recently it was recently the 30th
anniversary of the Tiananmen Square
massacre when you had hundreds of
thousands of Chinese citizens on the
streets of Beijing and across China
effect demanding democratic rights
demanding the right to freedom demanding
the right to choose their government a
very basic right that people like you
and I take for granted which people in
China don't have and when that massacre
happened 30 years ago in 1989 British
Democrats British liberals British
humanists were talking about it all the
time they were fully in favor of these
people who were struggling for the right
to democracy - for the right to a
democratic say in their lives and in
their communities on the 30th
anniversary however there was a real
sense of silence a lot of British
liberals who would normally have made a
big fuss about the Tiananmen Square
massacre India and the authoritarianism
of the Chinese regime didn't say
anything and I was thinking about this
and I thought ok this makes sense it's
because you are now on the same side as
the Chinese regime and that's not to say
you're going to drive tanks into trogir
Square like the Chinese regime did into
Tiananmen Square and Massacre people or
kill people but you're on the same side
in the sense that you think democracy is
overrated you think people shouldn't
have a free fair say in how their
community or their society is organized
and I thought that silence is so I think
your point is absolutely right there are
so many people around the world who
looked to the UK and to other Western
nations America too for an example of
people having a real say in how their
lives are organized who now will no
longer do that and you have foreign
regimes around the world that will look
at the UK really right and they'll see
that there are members of parliament and
government officials who are hell-bent
on over riding the largest Democratic
vote in the history of our country and
those regimes will say let's do the same
thing so let's just break down a little
of the chronology of this whole thing so
so the vote is about
two years ago then you said June of 2016
2016 yeah and then how soon were things
supposed to be in motion
straight away it was supposed to happen
very very quickly and David Cameron who
was Prime Minister and George Osborne
who was the Chancellor of the exec yeah
he was the in charge of the economy
these two figures who were the leading
figures in he in the United Kingdom
argued that it would happen straightaway
we will listen to you we will act upon
what you say we will do it right off the
bat so everyone was expecting that would
happen in a matter of weeks or months
and people went to the ballot box with
that view in mind they thought right
this is the this is the first election
in which I'm not simply being asked to
choose between a party who will run the
country we're all asked that in every
single election we take part in this was
a different election this was an
election in which we were being asked to
decide the political makeup of the
nation the constitutional nature of the
nation should we be entangled with the
European Union or should would be
completely independent of it so a lot of
voters I spoke to said that this is the
first time they felt that their vote had
real consequence and would change the
country entirely
so people relish the opportunity voter
turnout went up enormous ly it was 72%
normally it's around 60% so there was a
huge rise in voter turnout especially in
working-class areas and poor areas where
people don't normally vote and people
came out in their millions and said
let's leave the European Union and they
expected it would happen very quickly
more than three years later it's thought
so what happened that caused the pause
the delay and now the possible reversal
of this day well the the key issue is
that the political class doesn't want to
leave the European Union I mean this is
the great tension in the United Kingdom
at the moment and I think is actually
reflected in American politics to a
certain extent to and across Europe in
fact as well in the UK a majority of
voters want to leave the European Union
but a majority of the
past doesn't and that's the key tension
say for example 52% of people voted to
leave the European Union that's a
majority seventeen and a half million
but in the political class seventy
percent of members of parliament voted
to stay in the European Union with the
Labour Party which is our version of the
Democrat Party it was 95 percent 95
percent of Labour MPs voted to stay in
the European Union I mean that is how
utterly disconnected the supposedly
left-wing party is from public sentiment
I mean it is simply extraordinary that
95 percent of Labour MPs as against just
48 percent of the public voted to stay
in the European Union so we have this
difficult historically unprecedented
situation where the people want one
thing and the political class want
another and and the great unfortunate
thing is that the political class is
getting its way so ok so I think the
average person listening to this at
least from an American lens would go
well wait a minute we have elections and
no matter what the result is incumbents
get booted and they gotta go we bring in
this guy this whole thing happens they
keep telling us that trumps never gonna
leave office but in many ways and you
will Democrats yeah except this is all I
got ok all that so what actually is
happening I mean are they literally just
that that percentage that 70% they're
just saying we're just not going to put
the processes in motion that would allow
for we're just so they're they're not
denying that they're denying the will of
the people I guess that's what I'm
asking right or are they or they're
saying you're true you were tricked
right doesn't yes it's a lot that you
were tricked into voting for this and
we're doing what's better for you that's
the key thing so that so they would
never openly say we hate the will of the
people you think you're all idiots and
we're just going to ignore you yeah a
little bit right so they they had they
put a bit of spin on it they put it
they'd put a kind of PC gloss on the
fact that they are actually undermining
the democratic process so what they say
is we were tricked we will lie to we're
a bunch of idiots they crazy
we're races with xenophobic the phrase
they used is low in for me
you are which is a fancy phrase for you
know stupid but that's what they say
you're low information you didn't have
all the information you didn't
understand the consequences of leaving
the European Union you know you're not
educated enough you're not switched on
enough you know even people like Richard
Dawkins have been saying it was wrong
and stupid to entrust such a big
political decision to ordinary people
because they think we are inferior to
their history Donna it's me but it's
such an important moment because I think
it really sums up where politics is
going where politically correct politics
is going where woke politics is going
because what it's doing is creating this
almost this neo aristocracy where you
have this layer of people who think they
know better than us they know how you
should speak in Asia how you should
behave they know how you should think
and they are superior to us that they
are educated they went to the right
universities they have the right
attitudes and then down here there are
the kind of the throng the masses the
idiots who don't speak in the right way
who don't have the right attitudes who
aren't sufficiently PC who aren't
sufficiently woke and they can be bossed
around they can be ignored they can be
told what to do and tell what to think
so I think actually that the war against
brexit which is fundamentally a war
against democracy actually speaks to the
political culture of the Western world
more broadly where you have this the
creation of this two-tier political
system where at the top you have these
switched-on elites who think they know
better than the rest of us and they have
no concern at all about bossing us
around and censoring us and demonizing
us and telling us we're stupid and
blocking the things that we vote for so
I think at the heart of brexit what we
can see is it is the elites war against
supposedly deplorable people so now
there were three plus years into this do
you think the damage has been done
regardless and at a certain level that
even if somehow brexit is pulled off and
it limps out yeah that the the faith in
the system will have been so beat and I
my friends that are British most of them
actually were pro brexit and they are so
deeply depressed about how this whole
situation has been dealt with that it
almost seems to me that no matter what
happens now that is going to be very
hard to reset I think that's absolutely
a key question which is whether they've
already gone too far you know I kind of
I flit from day to day about weather
breaks it will happen on that but then I
also think precisely that even if it
does happen now have we gone too far
down the route of anti democracy because
what it's it's extraordinary and and - a
lot of American people and other non
British people will be difficult to
comprehend just how extraordinary it's
been but for more than three years the
majority of people in the UK the
majority of voters have been subjected
to relentless daily abuse we've been
told we are ignorant we are stupid we
are racist we are xenophobic we are
driven by a hatred of foreigners we are
driven by a hatred of immigration we've
been told basically that we're scum and
then the way you have your your police
departments in London tweeting out that
we should be watching people for hate
speech that's right other thing that's
right so that at the exact same time
there is this constant policing of what
we say in how we express ourselves and
so there are millions and millions of
people in the UK who just feel
completely beaten down and abused and
treated like crap to be frank by the
political class by the political elites
and they've had enough of it but the
question arises of how they respond to
that
will they respond to that by saying we
give up or will they respond to that by
saying we're going to fight back and
that's the key question off the moment
in the UK and I think across the Western
world in fact and Nigel Farage that I
interviewed Nigel fraud on my podcast a
few months ago and he made the point
that the two choices facing the British
population at the moment is anarchy or
apathy do you respond to this non-stop
abuse from the woke elites by being an
anarchist and saying well screw you
we're going to keep
I think for this thing that we want or
do you respond to it by being apathetic
and saying you win we give up and I see
that dilemma that choice repeated in
fact across the Western world which is
do ordinary people respond to the
relentless harassment of them by the
political class and the media class and
the woe class do they respond to that by
saying well no we don't accept this and
we're going to keep pushing it back
against your eccentric crazy political
worldview or do they respond to it by
saying we're going to slink off into our
own lives and give up on politics
entirely that I think is the crossroads
that the West is that yeah that seems to
be it for everybody yeah whether you're
dealing with brags that or even what's
going on here which are you going to get
engaged and where does that lead you and
how crazy will you have made those
people in a certain way if you've
treated them so deplorably yes sometimes
so obviously I wanted to bring up Rajan
is I've met him a few times we had we
had lunch in London I found him to be
exactly the way he is publicly which is
boisterous and passionate and all of
those things and and you know sort of
endlessly overjoyed and but yet he's
dealing with all sorts of nonsense all I
sense from him though really sort about
the political level was that he wants
his people to be free
it was really all I got from him do you
think there is more to it than that or
do you think that that is enough and you
know he he won the other election just
in the last two yes where does this sort
of place him so Nigel Farraj that his
most recent outlet is the brexit party
so he has set up a new political party
called the brexit party and they won the
European Union elections
I mean this is how outbreak was where
they were formed when three weeks before
or a few weeks before and they won they
got more than 5 million votes they beat
the Conservative Party they'd be the
Labour Party they'd be the Liberal
Democrat Party which are the three main
parties in the UK be all of them and
they won and they are now the largest
political party in the European
Parliament from across the whole of
Europe they are the largest party that
is that is how strong the sentiment is
in the UK for brexit people are still
voting
it breaks it again and again at every
opportunity they get so nigel has set up
this party I think it's a very admirable
exercise I think he is someone who
genuinely wants the UK to leave the
European Union and in fact he has
devoted his working life to that for the
past 2025 years he was originally a
leader of the UK Independence Party and
now he's the leader of the brexit party
but all along the way he has been
arguing that we have to leave the
European Union because it is
anti-democratic
and illiberal and a really foul
institution and he's absolutely right he
organized a huge rally outside
parliament a few months ago called the
leave means leave rally ie leaving the
European really should mean leaving the
European Union which I was one of the
speakers at that so I got to meet him
got to speak to him and I much got the
impression firstly that he is someone
who is genuinely committed to recovering
Britain's national sovereignty and
Britain's popular democracy against this
kind of encroaching oligarchical
institution in Brussels and I also got a
sense from the vast crowds who were
there the thousands of people many of
whom came up to me afterwards to talk to
me about what I had said got a very
clear sense that there are huge numbers
of ordinary people who want the same
thing who want us to leave the European
Union who want Britain to go back to go
back to being an independent nation so
it wasn't just a big party for racists
know who aid immigrants and hate gay
people on the rest of it it's so
infuriating I think you know the thing
that I think infuriates me most about
contemporary politics is the way in
which people are so are so casually
written off it's a new way of saying
you're scum so we don't have to deal
with you but instead of saying you're
scum which would be unpitying itself
they say you're racist you're xenophobic
you're Islamophobic you're transphobic
you're all these phrases that they've
invented simply to demonize certain
points of view and that's been used
against brexit voters who are all
written off as xenophobic
it's been used against numerous sections
of society who simply want to defend
liberal values or traditional values or
conservative values or any view of life
that runs counter to the politically
correct elite anyone who does that
instantly runs the risk of being
denounced as phobic in some way and
that's such a dangerous approach how
would you connect this to what's going
on more broadly with labor in general so
you mentioned that 90% of them yeah
don't want to leave earth right that 90%
of them don't want yeah which is against
the will of the people that's one thing
but now there's all this giant you know
anti somatic scam yeah korban which now
is starting I think we're seeing the
seeds of it here with the Democrats yeah
I think this new woke class of Democrats
they're teasing out the very things and
I see this from a lot of conservative
British pundits they'll say yeah that's
the type of talk that we started hearing
about six seven years ago and now it
seems like it's taken over labour
entirely
I completely agree I think absolutely
you're absolutely right to draw that
connection between the kind of prejudice
that is growing up in the Labour Party
in the UK under Jeremy Corbyn who is
this kind of supposedly radical Marxist
leader and the kind of prejudices that
you will see unexpressed among you know
the kind of radical wing of the Democrat
Party which is this increasingly
anti-semitic worldview and the the the
conclusion I've come to is the identity
politics is a gateway drug to actual
racism because what identity politics
does I mean it does so many bad things
it rehabilitates racial thinking it
divides everyone according to their
biological origins rather than a
question of their character and who they
are and what they believe so it's a very
regressive form of politics but I think
the worst thing that it does is the way
it organizes every ethnic group and
social group according to whether
they're privileged or oppressed and and
it has this obsessive desire to locate
every single group in this kind of
of victimhood and what that does it it's
meant to generate sympathy for the most
oppressed groups which apparently
includes I don't know in America would
include African Americans and Muslims
and so on
it's meant to generate sympathy for them
but what it does by extension is
generate hatred and bile for supposedly
privileged groups white men straight men
sis people I don't use the word sis but
they do use the word says and choose
because what this these racist
identitarian 's have done they have
decided in their infinite wisdom that
the idea that the jews of victims is
over egged and exaggerated and not
really accurate anymore and in fact we
have to relocate the jews away from this
good group ie victims into this bad
group ie privileged people and as a
consequence of that a lot of the bile
that these people throw out the racist
vile I would say is targeted at not only
white men insist people and so on but
also at Jewish people so I think
actually the contemporary anti-semitism
is not a product of the the politics of
racial superiority as it was in the
1930s and the 1940s it's a product of
the politics of identity it's a product
of woek politics which has this kind of
myopic urge to divide all these groups
according to whether they are deserving
of our sympathy or deserving of our
hatred it's so interesting this idea
that if you supposedly care about this
group that you view lower that it's
lower in the hierarchy that it can't
just be about that it has to then just
the way human nature is yes has to be
about hating some guys know exactly
right and what it mostly ends up doing I
would argue is it's probably 80% focused
on the hatred of yes and whatever that
group might be and 20% yeah ends up
being left on these people usually with
the wrong solutions absolutely right I
mean we see this now in America you know
whatever all these things and with
Harvard and they didn't want a certain
amount of Asian people there so they
start having quotas and we're
literally punishing Asian people for
working hard and focusing on family and
education no one came age in people
anything when they came here just like
no one gave Irish people are Italian
people yeah which people already what
anything you get here in your ear yeah
look I think that's absolutely right and
I if anything I think it might even be
more than 80 percent as their focus of
hatred
you're being very balanced there but I
think that's right it's it's you know
everyone loses out as so as a
consequence of the hierarchy of
victimhood obviously the privileged
groups the supposedly privileged groups
lose out because they are the subjects
of hatred it's acceptable to hate them
in fact it's it's socially responsible
to hate them it's socially responsible
to hate white men is it crazy when you
hear some of these people what I see and
the Twitter version of this is that
what's coming soon enough within 10
years will actually be laws against
these people that will punish these
people yeah and I think if I would have
heard that three years ago it would have
sounded crazy now it's starting to sound
kind of right that if you if really the
ideas of Labor and what's being borne
out of our Democrats coming now
it won't just be about oh we want
everybody to have you know take from
some and give to others just for tax
purposes but it'll be about more
proactive ways yeah to punish certain
people and now you know we're talking
about reparations now and a whole slew
of other things I think that's already
happening in some ways where you have a
situation where you know on campuses on
universities and in other areas of life
you have affirmative action and other
measures you know many of which started
out with good intentions which are now
being used to elevate certain social
groups and to demean or handicap other
social groups I think we're already seen
the origins of that I think it will go
further and further you know one of my
big problems with this culture of hatred
towards certain privileged groups is
that it's so anti intellectual it's so
wrong you know so for example white men
is it's absolutely acceptable and in
fact cherished to hate white men and you
think so well hold on white men includes
very poor people hard-working people the
the man who cleans your toilet the man
who
fixes things in your house when they go
wrong it includes fire fighters who will
save your life you ungrateful
idiots if anything bad happens it
includes soldiers includes all these
people and then it includes incredibly
wealthy people and credit you know the
minority people who run businesses
people who are bosses and so on so what
the politics of identity does I think
one of the key things it does it
completely erases the question of class
it completely erases the question of who
has things and who doesn't have things
and that's someone who comes from the
left
traditionally I find that really
worrying where a whole swathe of people
is just categorized as bad on the basis
of the color of their skin with no
discussion about the divisions within
that group of people in terms of class
in terms of influence in terms of work
and everything else so to me it's just
as bad as when I was growing up and
people would do the same in relation to
black people they would say all black
people are questionable by the basis
that they have a certain skin color that
was wrong that was wicked that was an
evil approach to life because it didn't
take into consideration the fact that
there are vastly different kinds of
black people the majority of them are
good hard-working decent people and if
some are committing crimes it tends to
be a minority it tends to be a specific
problem so it was racist to suggest that
all black people were a problem i
similarly think it's racist to say it's
racially charged to suggest that white
men are a bad thing it doesn't take into
consideration the fact that there are
vast moral class political differences
in this way the people so since this
woke monster that's what I always call
it it's a buzzer it's sort of an
amorphous monster that you can't quite
shape or fully understand because it's
always changing and changing the rules
and all those things but because it
doesn't seem to really be going anywhere
let's say do you think that that the
populist movements that are now rising
up all over Europe are the only way to
get out of this and are you worried
about that where that could potentially
lead because I think this is a little
bit where every time you talk about
populism
you start talking about nationalism yaks
thing you know people think you're
talking about F no national yeah and
there's this weird sliding scale so
maybe if you could kind of break down
yeah view those differently
well I'm very Pro populist I'm very anti
ethno-nationalism and I don't think
there's a contradiction between those
two things at all okay so can you just
lay those out yes so I think populism is
an incredibly positive moment now that
doesn't mean that all the populist
movements around the world are good some
of them are good some of them are very
questionable some of them have bad ideas
but I do think all of them in the round
represent a rebellion against the
technocratic politically correct elites
that have risen up over the past thirty
years and we can see this with the boat
for brakes at the vote for brakes it was
a very clear statement of opposition to
the bureaucratic elites that run the
United Kingdom we can see it with the
Julie Jones in France who have been
protesting on the streets every single
week for about 30 weeks now I mean for a
long period of time they get virtually
no media coverage but you certainly was
either on see you right you don't see
anything about brexit you won't see on
CNN but you we don't even get coverage
of the Geonosians on the BBC and we live
right next door to France we live twenty
six miles from France
it is our closest friend me and we we
don't get the coverage of what's
happening that's absolutely
extraordinary but I think with the
solutions that's very clearly a protest
against Emmanuel macron the president of
France who is a elitist paternalistic
bureaucratic politician and we can see
across Europe there are various
left-wing and right-wing populist
movements emerging pushing aside the
kind of traditional social democratic or
right-wing parties and saying we need a
new kind of politics I think you can
also see in the in the US with the Trump
phenomenon now I don't think the Trump
phenomenon is uncomplicated I think is
very complicated I think there are many
problems with Trump as an individual and
as a politician and in terms of what he
says and what it does but I think the
vote for him through the electoral
college everyone will say he didn't win
the popular vote we know this but
through the electoral college the fact
that he won is incredibly significant
and I think it represented a
particularly among working-class voters
where they were saying we've had enough
of the establishment we've had enough of
the establishment politics woke politics
the kind of thing that Hillary and
others were pushing the problem in the
US as far as I can see I think the
Democrats have gone completely nuts
because what they have done is they are
going further and further down the root
of the kind of politics that the people
have rejected so let me pause you there
physics so since we're saying that we
should view what's going on with labor
now in the UK as a sort of precursor to
what's happening with the Democrats yeah
people always ask me this well is there
any sign that it's going to stop and I
cannot find a sign that at any moment
over these last couple years where the
left went bananas
and identity politics and all these
things and Trump became president as if
that wasn't a big enough sign I've never
seen a moment where the self-reflection
kicked in no was there any moment in
Labour's dissent that you saw like a
moment where suddenly there was a chance
I mean even if it didn't actually
materialize but a chance where you go
now now they could kind of recalibrate
that's to get back to something cuz yeah
we seem you know they throw and Biden
basically is the last chance yeah he was
like take this old guy who now he's
gonna try to play your woke game - yeah
but but he's the last thing we got
that's the great tragedy of Biden I
think he keeps getting attacked by these
woke politicians and he keeps giving in
too much to them you think stand up for
yourself Joe do you know any way you can
like him how much but man if exactly
they end up to them I would be all about
he could clean up but you know in the UK
that's a really good question because I
think there were a few moments where
Labour thought to itself
where are we going and in fact there are
still sections of the Labour Party as
small sections who are saying we've gone
too far
we've gone too far down the Metropolitan
elitist a kind of woke political route
and we need to recover what we were
traditionally about which was about
being a democratic party a battery a
patriotic party a nationalist party it
sort of gets us back to where we started
this interview actually because I
asking you can you stay in something and
fix it from the inside or somehow yeah
my view and I've said this to labor
supporting friends of mine my view is
that labor cannot be fixed it's lost
because this has been a long time coming
in fact and I think it's been a long
time coming from the left across the
Western world and and they've made the
wrong decision again and again and again
and they've gone so far down the root of
this kind of elitist distant
paternalistic politics but I think it'll
be very hard for them to come back from
that so the point I make to labor
supporting friends of mine who are still
Pro brexit pro-democracy who think
ordinary people are decent and sensible
rather than idiots I always say to them
you just got to leave you've got to set
up your own organization got to do your
own thing because there's a lost cause
but I think looking at the US I'm I'm
just amazed at the mistakes that the
Democratic Party are making and I just
think they are making all the same
mistakes of the British left have made
they're going you know this is why I
have this soft spot for Bernie Sanders
not in the sense of economics I think
his economic program is like oh no
that's really not good but there's a
really interesting tension between the
traditional leftism of Bernie Sanders
which tends to be pretty much
class-based and the woek leftism of the
New Democrats and the new left and you
can see it when they keep firing back at
Bernie saying well you're an old white
man you know we don't need another old
white man we need a young black woman
who apparently is superior by dint of
her racial origin right would you say
that's Karma in a little way because I
yes I've been saying it it is coming
years like they are good it's not that
they're just gonna pass on him and all
the polls are showing that now he's lost
all his mojo yeah it's not just that
because he's yesterday's news and he's a
straight white man it's that they're
gonna have to destroy him yes absolutely
they have to vengefully destroy him yeah
and watching that happen is going to be
well it gets to what we talked about
before about it's not about saving the
20% how do you help them and try to
destroy the yeah thing and they're gonna
have to do it and it's gonna in a weird
way I'm gonna sort of enjoy them doing
it as you know you mean like I don't
inherently
that's not how I am yeah but it's like
you sort of created this thing I get it
yeah like the fully woke thing but
you're kind are and now congratulations
it's like them calling Pelosi racist
well I completely agree I think when
politicians like Sanders and Pelosi and
others give in too much to the woke
agenda they sign their own death warrant
I think that's a very clear case of
what's happened with Bernie Sanders in
particular you know I think back to that
turning point in fact when he was
accosted by black lives matters
activists and he invited them onto stage
and they write and what he should have
said is no shut the hell up I'm talking
you can ask questions at the end and he
would have got so much support among
ordinary people if he had taken that
that approach to these arrogant people
who thought that by dint of their
origins and their beliefs that they had
the right to to Swan on to any stage and
express themselves I think he would have
won so much public support if it stood
up to that but again and again that's
one example again and again he has given
in too much to the woke agenda so he's
kind of signed his own warrant in many
ways but I do think that if he were to
break away if he were to say I don't
care about your skin color don't care
about your sex don't care about your
gender don't care about your sexuality I
care about what you believe I care about
where you stand on political questions
and economic questions and that's all
that I'm going to judge you by I think
he'd win a lot of support and in some
ways that's what because I sort of too
late for him it's still yes I think it
could be too I think if he had done that
he would have won a lot of support but
he made the wrong judgments on so many
different so basically that there was a
moment maybe there wasn't my mode before
it went completely bananas where it's at
now but you know I always find it
fascinating that Trump has always been
quite sympathetic to Bernie Sanders and
he'll write very clever move I think
actually bizarrely they have something
in common which is a desire to rise
above the kind of [ __ ] woke crappy
PC politics and to speak directly to
ordinary people and say well what is
really concerning you what are the real
issues in your life let's talk about
those
Trump has done that more successfully
than Bernie Sanders I say this is
someone who is not Pro Trump but he has
done it more successfully because Bernie
has given in too much to the other
distracting authoritarian PC agendas but
there is a there was I shouldn't say
there is there was a commonality between
these two men which was how can we go
above this bad politics which has taken
the Western world by grip and talk to
ordinary people about what's concerning
them and their everyday lives both of
those had that instinct I think Bernie
has jettisoned that instinct and has
gone too far down the work crew so I
think your apps if you people want to
take kind of karma retribution in the
fact that he's going to be destroyed I
think that's fine because he made bad
choices yeah it's just crappy it's yes
it just is but okay so let's link this
back to to the populism that you're
talking about so I understand that and
then what what is either the connection
or the disconnection between that and
then nationalism and what then veers
into what we should all be worried about
which is actually ethno-nationalism
yes so I think I'm a national populism
is a pretty good thing because I think
the only way democracy can work in a
real way like dude I mean meaningful
democracy where everyone regardless of
their station in society regardless of
how much money they have
regardless have a much how much
education they have everyone has the
right to an equal say in how societies
organized I think that's an incredibly
important political value I think in
many ways it's the key political value
the only way that value can be upheld is
if you have a coherent nation a nation
which is not interfered with too much by
outside forces which is not bossed
around by a foreign oligarchy like the
European Union which by the way can
write laws that US British people must
live by even though we have no direct
mechanism for pushing aside the people
who write those laws so it's fundamental
when outsourced all your freedom right
for people in Brussels amazing right so
we don't want to outsource our freedom
we don't want to outsource our
democratic decision-making processes but
that's
what has happened so I see national
populism as an attempt to recover the
ideal of democracy and and borders are
actually central to the idea of
democracy because if a nation doesn't
control its own borders then it really
isn't a nation at all and if it isn't a
nation at all then it cannot have
democracy which can only really in any
meaningful sense take place within a
nation humanity has not thought of any
other way that democracy can work other
than in a nation so where do some how
people sort of think that borders are
are somehow against freedom yeah but
actually they're the only things that
ensure free absolutely and I think the
right of a nation to police its borders
into control is board is this is
essential now as it happens I'm very
liberal on the question of immigration I
would like a liberal policy on
immigration in the UK and everywhere
else but I think it's the onus is on me
to argue for that in the democratic
sphere rather than having a situation
where in Europe for example the European
Union determines how many migrants
people country should take so that's
implicitly anti-democratic or over here
in the US you have a situation where you
have these kind of supposedly radical
eccentric Democrats who just think
everyone should be able to come to the
US regardless of whether they come
through the legal port of entry
regardless of whether they've tried to
do it in the in the reasonable way they
should think the people should be able
to swarm into the country and and and do
as they please what these two things
have in common is an hostility towards
the idea of borders but it's an Hass
it's a hostility towards the idea of
borders that's not based on freedom but
it is based on the idea that the nation
is a is a bad thing and and that
democracy is a bad thing and that we
should just throw everything open and
allow other people to decide the fate of
the country that's fundamentally
anti-democratic you I'm sure you're
familiar with your own house onie
and the virtue of nationalism yes yeah
so that that basically I think you just
summed up his book write quite
eloquently there that we need these
things to protect freedom so what's the
part then that we have to watch out for
as these movements rights
ethno-nationalism is a repugnant idea
it's it's absolutely a disgusting idea
and I say that as you know I live in the
United Kingdom but I'm not originally a
British person
my parents were Irish they came to the
UK I'm the I'm a first generation
British person so you know all these
people who say go back home you don't
belong here you've only been here for a
few years I mean that applies to me
right I've only my family has only been
in the UK for 45 years or so in terms of
when my parents came over so we're very
new arrivals the idea of
ethno-nationalism would expel us
instantly and it would expel so many of
the people I grew up with black people
Asian people Indian people Chinese
people all these people that grew up
with who I know for a fact felt a real
sense of attachment to the United
Kingdom as a nation as a political
project as a democracy so the ugly thing
about ethno-nationalism is that it
determined citizenship on the basis of
race on the basis of skin color on the
basis of the native istic idea of where
your family comes from the great live
ads are the same coin that sounds a lot
awful lot like that identity part
exactly and this is the great that is
such a key point because the great irony
of contemporary politics is the kinship
between these horrendous
ethno-nationalism one by skin color and
these horrendous identitarian who did
the exact same thing and and what both
sides share in common is this racial
obsessiveness this hyper racial
awareness where everyone has to be
judged according to their pigmentation
or other kind of biologically inherited
traits whereas I think the the really
progressive thing to do and I know
progressive means something different in
the u.s. than it does in Europe but the
really decent thing to do the really
decent thing to do is to judge people
not by their skin colour but by their
character I mean that famous
someone said it but you know holding on
to that idea is so important right now
character is what counts belief is what
counts your willingness to commit to the
nation and to your community that's what
counts it doesn't matter what color you
are doesn't matter what sex you are
doesn't matter who you sleep with it's
the question of who you are as an
individual and I think that is an
incredibly positive idea and it's under
attack from both sides it's under attack
from the supposedly alright which I know
is an overused phrase but the ethno
nationalist and it's under attack from
the left identitarian and I think
defending that idea that you can be part
of a nation regardless of where you
originally come from is so important we
have our work cut out for us
which is why unfortunately I'm gonna let
you go now but we will do this again
soon it was definitely sooner than two
years yes please a lot more we can be
doing here brendan is wise enough not to
be on Twitter but you can follow spiked
online at at spiked online and don't
forget to click the subscribe button
right here on YouTube and make sure to
turn on notifications so that you can
actually see our videos in your feed how
novel I know it's crazy isn't it